ahora lo que vamos a ver para este
circuito rc es una traducción formal de
cómo lucen exactamente estas dos curvas
y después veremos una definición precisa
de la respuesta natural
ahora vamos a dibujar rápidamente
nuestro circuito aquí está la
resistencia
aquí el capacitor tenemos un voltaje
inicial de 0 en el capacitor y ahora
queremos encontrar vedete
aquí está r y aquí está también vamos a
etiquetar las corrientes en este
circuito
esta es la corriente en la resistencia y
esta es la corriente en el capacitor y
ahora vamos a escribir las dos
relaciones voltaje corriente en estos
dos componentes la ley de ohm me dice
que y es igual a 1 entre r por ver y la
corriente en un capacitor esta es r
y esta es c y la corriente en el
capacitor es igual a c por dv
dt estas son las dos corrientes en
nuestros dispositivos
ahora vamos a usar la ley de corrientes
de kircos en este nodo de aquí y esto
nos dice que todas las corrientes que
salen de este modo su suma tiene que ser
igual a cero vamos a hacerlo decimos que
y se más cierre es igual a cero esto es
el cec a la ley de corrientes de kirk os
si por dv dt + 1 / r volver es igual a 0
ahora vamos a dividir todo en 13 y nos
queda dv dt + 1 / rc por b igual a 0 y
nos referimos a esta expresión de aquí
como una ecuación diferencial ordinaria
tiene una derivada en ella y es lo que
la hace una ecuación diferencial y lado
significa que es ordinaria que solo
tiene una variable independiente de t
ustedes pueden buscar este término
de o en can academy y en los vídeos de
matemáticas verán diferentes formas de
resolver esta ecuación ahora vamos a
hacer lo mismo aquí lo que vamos a hacer
es tratar de encontrar una expresión
para bebé te vamos a definir de bt de
manera que esta ecuación sea verdadera
de manera que pongamos nuestra función
aquí cualquiera que ésta sea calculemos
su derivada la ponemos aquí y toda esta
expresión tiene que ser verdadera
un par de maneras de resolver esto y la
que vamos a usar aquí es adivinar una
respuesta aquí necesitamos una función
cuya derivada luzca como ella misma ya
que la suma de esto tiene que ser igual
a cero lo que significa que la función
be y la función dvd t tienen que tener
la misma forma para que su suma tenga la
posibilidad de ser igual a cero y la
función que yo conozco cuya derivada
luce igual que la función es la
exponencial así que vamos a proponer que
esto es una exponencial y esta
exponencial va a estar elevada a una
constante que podemos ajustar y
pondremos otra constante aquí y esta es
la solución que proponemos de manera que
la solución
dv dt sea algo que tenga una constante y
también tenga una exponencial elevada a
otra constante es deporte la forma en
que probamos nuestra solución es
sustituirla en la ecuación y ver si esta
ecuación se cumple si lo hace nuestra
solución fue la correcta
si no tendremos que probar otra cosa
aquí vamos a poner nuestra vedette y
también necesitamos la derivada de b con
respecto a t
dv dt es igual a la derivada con
respecto al tiempo
de cada por el ala ese porte y esto será
igual acá está ese baja y el ala st
permanece igual y ahora tenemos la
derivada de nuestra solución propuesta
ahora vamos a sustituir todo esto en la
ecuación para ver si se cumple ponemos
nuestra derivada más nuestra solución
propuesta y veremos si su suma es igual
a cero o no entonces es ese porque por
él a la s t más 1 / rc así se queda por
nuestra solución propuesta que es k por
el ala ese porte y esto debería ser
igual a cero vamos a factorizar el
término común y tenemos cada por el ala
st
por s más 1 / r por c y esto es igual a
analizamos esto cómo hacemos que esto
sea igual a 0
tenemos 3 términos en este producto
cualquiera de estos tres términos puede
ser igual a cero el primero si acá fuera
igual a cero sería algo aburrido ya que
nos dice que tenemos un circuito sin
energía así que esto no es interesante
ahora tenemos a la ese porte que
podríamos hacerlo igual a cero pero esto
nos llevaría mucho tiempo ya que
tendríamos que dejar que te fuera hacia
el infinito ese tendría que ser un
número negativo y te tendría que ir
hacia el infinito lo cual es mucho
tiempo de espera para que ocurra algo
así que esta solución tampoco es
interesante así que la parte interesante
es cuando ese más uno entre reporte es
igual a cero es más uno entre r por c
igual a cero
por lo que ese será igual a menos 1 / el
reporte y esto hace que esta solución
sea verdadera y si este es el caso
podemos decir que bb&t es igual a una
constante k por el ala menos t sobre el
reporte y aquí sucede algo interesante
fíjense en este término de menos t entre
el reporte todo este exponente no debe
tener unidades en el momento en el que
lo evaluamos lo que significa que el
reporte deben de tener unidades de
tiempo
rc se mide en segundos las unidades de r
por c sports nos dan segundos ya
encontramos ese y ahora necesitamos
encontrar que acá es una variable el
tiempo es una variable y el voltaje es
una variable si conociéramos b&t al
mismo tiempo podríamos encontrar acá y
hay un momento en el que sabemos esto y
es cuando t
a 0 cuando te es igual a 0 sabemos que
la batería se quitó y hay carga en el
capacitor por lo que sabemos que el
voltaje en el capacitor cuando te es
igual a cero va a ser igual a b 0 y aquí
tenemos un par de variables que
conocemos de ive al mismo tiempo
pongamos esto en nuestra solución
propuesta para ver cuál es el valor de k
de cuando te es igual a 0 es igual a de
0 y esto es igual acá por el ala menos
de que es 0
/ r porsche y toda esta expresión es que
a la 0 o igual a 1 por lo que nos queda
que acá es igual a b 0 k es el voltaje
inicial almacenado en el capacitor y
esto nos da nuestra respuesta final
es vedette es igual a b 0 nuestro
voltaje inicial por el ala menos
/ r porsche vamos a dar un paso más allá
y vamos a encontrar que es y dt y va a
ser igual a bb t / r que es la ley de
ohm por lo que y dt es igual a b 0 / r
por el ala menos t entre el reporte y
esta es la respuesta natural de un
circuito rc